[Music]
a coronavirus vaccine could be available
as early as next month as pharmaceutical
companies continue to make
massive progress thanks for joining us
at 11 i'm denise valdis and i'm brian
loftis operation warp speed has been an
unprecedented success with three
companies producing a covid vaccine
testing
at over 90 percent efficacy but some are
concerned by the potential
side effects of the vaccine or go mana
joining us live with more on what you
need to know
orca
well brian and denise the experts say
that the
possible side effects of the coronavirus
vaccine are relatively
mild they're encouraging everyone to get
the vaccine when it becomes available
but some people aren't quite convinced
these vaccines are safe they're
effective
and they prevent very serious disease
the key to combating copin 19
could be right around the corner
pharmaceutical companies pfizer moderna
and astrazeneca say their coronavirus
vaccines are extremely promising but
there's some concern about the side
effects the coven 19 vaccine is
administered in two doses but after the
first shot
some people may experience issues the
side effects are
a sore arm some feelings of fatigue
maybe some low-grade fevers and maybe
some muscle aches
but dr mark khan dean of the unlv school
of medicine says those symptoms can be
alleviated with over-the-counter
medications such as tylenol
these are very very relatively minor
side effects
compared to the lethality and the
morbidity of covid
itself dr khan urges everyone to make
sure they go back for the second shot as
it's meant to solidify a strong response
to the virus
another worry some people have is if the
vaccine will stay effective down the
road given how fast it was developed
the risk factor of it not being as safe
as we understand or know in the
intermediate or long
term is really my concern
there's so much we don't know about the
virus at this point in time and i think
there's going to be a large curve
before we get the vaccination right dr
khan says things have been quick
because of prior research a lot of this
was based on existing technology
applied to a new virus and while some
plan to hold off dr khan has a clear
message to nevadan
get vaccinated once you're able to get
the vaccine
there are currently three cova 19
vaccines that have finished their
stage 3 investigations but until the
vaccine is widely distributed
experts say that you should continue
practicing the basics
that includes hand washing social
distancing and of course
wearing your mask reporting live near
the las vegas strip tonight orca mana 8
news now